this film is beyond any of my
expectations it's amazing
hey youtubers it's Charlie and I totally
just got to see Loki the dark world I
mean wait
no Thor Thor the dark world and there's
just so much to talk about between new
Marvel projects as well as the next two
Avengers movies so first I'll do
favorite moments then I'll do my review
and then I'll talk about all the big
things that are coming for Marvel my
next couple of movies know where I'll
give a nice big warning before I talk
about spoilers you should really go into
this movie thinking about it like Marvel
Game of Thrones that's right alan taylor
the director actually directed a lot of
the best episodes of Game of Thrones
before he did this movie and one of the
reasons they picked him is because they
were really trying to bring this new
aesthetic to the film that's right if
you remember the first Thor film they
really depicted the Asgardians it's like
these alien beings but in this movie
they're really more Norse that goes into
the look of the film the costumes even
the soundtrack which was amazing it will
come as no surprise to anyone that Tom
Hiddleston is the runaway star of this
film obviously I made that joke about it
being located dark world there are a lot
of people calling for a Loki movie I'll
be doing a separate video about that be
sure to subscribe to get it but in this
movie you get this really deep emotional
look at Loki that you've never gotten
before and it's largely due to fricos
character Rene Russo's character his
mother without giving away too many
spoilers their characters you find out
has this really deep connection and you
find out that his mother actually taught
him a lot of the awesome things that he
can do I was actually really surprised
by how much I loved Rene Russo's
character in this film Frigga is a total
badass obviously if you read the comic
books you know this but most of us don't
read Thor all the time Odin on the other
hand is actually not much of a presence
in the film I was actually kind of
disappointed in his character it's
really just not quite as interesting as
Frigga
Loki or any of the other characters even
Natalie Portman's character is a lot
more interesting in this film she is
actually central to the plot in the film
which I was actually surprised by
because that wasn't really a case in the
first film the surprise here I did not
hate Natalie Portman in the film first
Emsworth is obviously a man of few words
in the film he actually does a pretty
good job but most of his best scenes are
with Loki obviously just because the two
of them work so well together most of
their dialogue heavy scenes though
aren't that great they actually take
place during the big special effects
sequences most of the scenes that I love
the most that they had together were
when they were not fighting one of the
funniest moments the
is actually a big spoiler so I'll talk
about that later in the video speaking
of funny can't dennings was actually one
of the big surprises of this film she
actually brought most of the humor in
addition to the Loki character don't be
surprised if a lot of people are calling
for them to have some sort of team-up in
a future project let's talk about the
soundtrack you can actually listen to it
for free on Spotify right now but I had
to listen to it all the way back from
the movie it was so amazing it really
does sound a lot like Game of Thrones
although it was a different person that
did the score for this film then did
Game of Thrones but one of the really
interesting things about my experience
of the film I went to a sneak preview of
the film was that it was almost
primarily a female audience so obviously
that gives you an idea for the demand
for a Loki movie Tom Hiddleston's Lady
Army is strong and powerful but what did
I think of the film overall I give it a
solid b-plus for its amazing sets and
costume design amazing soundtrack
amazing use of characters and its sense
of humor that's right it's one of the
funniest Marvel films that I've seen so
far it's hard to compete with warm up
but this movie actually came really
close like I said it actually addressed
a lot of complaints after the first Thor
film Natalie Portman's character becomes
a much bigger part of the story so it
feels like she's necessary the film was
a lot funnier a lot of the aspects of
the Thor culture and the story of Thor
are just a little bit ridiculous and the
film actually plays on that in a really
funny way I typically go to movies like
this just expecting to have a good time
and the film totally delivered on that
promise but it also did a really good
job of teeing up all the next Marvel
movies that are coming including Captain
America the Winter Soldier which is the
next film coming in the spring guardians
of the galaxy as well as Avengers 3 but
in order to talk more about those will
have to do spoilers so if you don't want
to hear any spoilers just turn the
volume down but one of the funniest
moments in the film was actually Tom
Hiddleston changing characters that's
right you know he can change his
appearance so he actually changed into
Captain America and this really funny
scene so Chris Evans actually had a
small cameo in the film although it was
obviously done in green-screen he wasn't
there on set with them he also learned
from this Frigga their mother it was
basically the one that taught Loki how
to do this taught him his magic
obviously the end of the film kind of
teases that Loki is still alive and
gonna be causing all kinds of mischief
all over the Marvel Universe we're not
gonna see him in Avengers 2 so we will
see him in Avengers 3 though that is
probably when they'll bring him back
Darcy actually had a scene where she
called shield and they weren't picking
up we actually learned why that is in
Captain America the Winter Soldier
shield is in a really bad place right
now agents of shield is actually doing a
Thor crossover in a couple weeks and
they'll kind
bridge the gap between those two films
just a little bit the next film after
that is guardians of the galaxy but the
infinity stone is a teaser for Avengers
3 that's the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
that'll be when Thanos basically tries
to assemble all the six infinity gems
it's this is going to take all of phase
2 and phase 3 to assemble all those
infinity gems there are six of them and
obviously it was really hard just to
even get this one I'll talk more about
the other Avengers movies as well as the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline in a
separate video be sure to subscribe to
get it you can turn the volume back up
now like I said agents of shield is
doing a thoracotomy I actually do videos
for that every week click here right now
to learn more about agents of shield
this season and you can click here to
watch my breakdown of the Captain
America Winter Soldier trailer if you
haven't seen the movie go out and see it
now thanks so much for watching high
five see you guys tonight pakora